so we are going to talk about two
problems now about china assignment and
subgraph isomorphism and we are going to
show
some common techniques that can be used
in order to show
lower bounds for those two so let us
start from the classical graph coloring
problem we have a graph and we want to
color its vertices in such a way that if
we have an edge then the colors of both
two end points needs to be different
we can understand this problem in such a
way that on every edge we have a number
one and this number one stands for the
minimum allowed difference
of the colors of the endpoints so now we
can generalize it
the generalized version is a channel
assignment problem and we have for
example if we have number five then the
difference of the colors of the
endpoints needs to be at least five it
can be can be more but at least five so
um
the formal definition is that we have a
graph we have a white function and we
are looking for a proper assignment that
is
an assignment that satisfies
all the
all the constraints of the of the edges
and also has a minimum span of colors
note that we can have gaps i mean the
colors that we are not using inside but
the the total span
uh needs to be as possible so uh if we
have such a problem
um then it is motivated by
by radio emitters and interference
interferences between those
and in fact a few days before this
workshop a friend of mine asked me about
this problem because he has something
like this with his wi-fi emitters
and
so so this problem in fact occurs in in
the in the real world and unfortunately
i had bad news for him because
the best known algorithm is brute force
that is checking all the maybe not not a
brute force but an algorithm that checks
all the all the permutations of those
vertices
uh
and there's nothing better unfortunately
although for uh
for l bounded version where l is
bound for the weight on the edges
there was some rays of dynamic
programming algorithms and maybe
something will be in the future
we do not know whether our lower bands
for those are tight or not
so
the channel assignment problem is a part
of a larger csp problems hierarchy and
we at the moment we know pretty much
about the complexities in this hierarchy
let us focus on the channel assignment
lower bounds
we have we have a title our band for it
which comes from this chain of of
reductions
the interesting part the most
interesting part is in the middle here
because here we are compressing the size
of of the instance from a linear
to a subliner let us take a look how
exactly we are compressing what is an
idea behind this compression we are
encoding
information inside permutations let us
assume that we have three permutations
like this
and
each one of those permutations is
encoding some part of the information
and we want to merge those three into a
new permutation in such a way that
all the all the information from the
from this left part is still preserved
in the right picture
and during the merge we will introduce
some new pieces of information to this
so let us
look
at the second coordinate of the right
picture
and note that
the second coordinate here is exactly
the same as the second coordinate here
so we are using the second coordinate to
preserve the information from the from
the left picture it is enough uh
all the all the information is preserved
so we can use the first coordinate
in
in any way we want to use it so we can
say for example that those first
three elements will pick the first
coordinate for themselves
uh and we will we'll put the first
coordinate of the rest arbitrary so the
first vertex is choosing three the
second is choosing one and the third is
choosing again three
so
we have preserved all the information
from the left part in the right part and
in addition to that we have encoded
three additional choices with three
options per each choice
so um when we are using this recursive
schema i mean we are starting from
let's say k uh trivial one element
permutations and we are merging them
recursively
then on each level of this recursion we
are encoding
a constant fraction of of k
uh additional pieces of information and
we and we have uh
we have a logarithmic number of levels
of this recursion so if we have k
elements we can encode k log k
asymptotically
pieces of of information so if we want
for example to encode n bits it is
sufficient to take
big o of n divided by log n elements and
take permutations on them so this is the
general idea behind this compression
here
all the rest is just gadgeting and we
are ending up with this
beautiful instance of channel assignment
this instance has
n divided by log n vertices
asymptotically
so we are obtaining a tight lower bound
for the channel assignment problem and
additional lower bound for the l-bounded
version
but we we do not know whether it is
tight or not
so
now we can move with this technique to
subgraph isomorphism
somewhat of isomorphism is
is a problem where we are asking whether
graph g
is a sub graph of graph h
what can be our our more most basic uh
approach to tackle such a such a problem
oh sorry not this side so um the best
note algorithm is um
uh is a brute force
let us assume for the simplicity that
both graphs have n vertices
so
the best known is brute force checking
all the all the permutations actually
all the all the assignments
and the question was whether it can be
solved in
c to the n and the answer is no it
cannot
so how we can tackle such a problem we
can start from taking let's say
variables of our sat formula
and packing them in into packs of
logarithmic size and assigning those
packs to the vertices of the graph g
we can we can then consider consider
vertices of the graph h
as valuations of those packs
and uh if we have a mapping
such that for example this vertex is
coming to
to this evaluation then then it stands
for that x4 x4 is equal to zero
x5 is equal to one and x6 is equal to
zero what is the problem uh the most
basic problem with this approach the
problem is that
we may want to reuse the same the same
vertex of h many times we may want to
reuse
reduce some valuation
multiple times
but
what we can work with what we can use
here we can use permutations of those
vertices because permutations are legal
functions from here to here
and in fact if you use the same
recursive schema to to to say
uh which vertex is choosing uh
the assignment for for which value then
we will obtain
using the same the same schema as for
the channel assignment we obtain the
division um
of the variables into packs of different
sizes but the size of the pack will be
limited by uh by a logarithm
and
and then
for for each evaluation of all the
variables there will exist a permutation
such that
uh such that
for this this permutation will stand for
this this this valuation so so we'll
have a permutation for for everything
but we are we are getting we are getting
here uh
different packs of different sizes okay
one of the other problems we can we can
occur
uh
one of the other problems that can occur
during this approach is problem of
configs because for example if we if we
put one
pack of variables to some assignment
then maybe maybe we cannot put some
another pack of variables variables to
some other assignment
so we have conflicts between between
those assignments and
we need to to
capture those conflicts somehow in our
instance
so we can modify slightly a problem and
add colors
for each kind of of conflict and we can
start from most the most naive approach
so
each conflict between each pair is a
different color here and because we we
have only n divided by local vertices
and
we are saying what
where we can put such a pair and where
it is impossible but it is way way too
too too large number of colors
after thinking a little bit we are we
are discovering that conflicts are
connected to the variables so we can
have only one type of of conflict per
one variable but if we digest it a
little bit more and we take a look on
the structure of of uh permutation
encoding itself and we if we are a
little bit more careful with this then
we can we can
force the number of colors to be only
logarithmic so we can use only a
logarithmic number of colors it's it's
related to the position of uh
of the variable inside of a pack all
right so so so many variables we will
will share the same color of conflict
but they will be on the on the same
position
but in the different packs so so so this
is tightly related to to to this to this
packing
of variables uh into packs of
logarithmic sites
but
finally if we have only this number of
colors then we can get back to our
original problem but by by some
gadgeting
and if if we have only n divided by log
n vertices then we can multiply the
number of vertices by a square root of
the number of colors so square root of
log n and
get
get the the number of vertices of a new
graph without colors on the on the edges
so we are getting a graph with n divided
by square root of log n
uh vertices
and this already gives us uh
a lower bound for subgraph isomorphism
we know from this that subgraph
isomorphous cannot be solved in time 2
to the n times square root of log n
under under eth
okay so so it this was cool but
we we have used a sophisticated way of
compressing in permutations and we
moreover
we were very careful during during this
packing to to avoid too many kinds of
conflicts so it was it was quite complex
it can be done much much simpler
so
what was the problem with our uh with
our first naive approach of packing the
problem was that maybe this vertex is
needed two times and we cannot afford it
in in subgraph isomorphism because we
can use on this only once
but what if we knew that this is this
one is needed two times this this is
needed zero this is needed one this is
needed one
uh one time
if we if we knew that then we can just
copy those vertices that many times
so this one is copied twice
and we have we have a perfect instance
of of
subgraph isomorphism now so
so maybe it is sufficient
sufficient to iterate through all the
possibilities
of of the number of times how how many
times we are using each vertex
and
and just create another instance for
such each such such a possibility so
uh
what is the number of those
possibilities it is single exponential
because it is a problem of uh balls and
beans we have we have cables those balls
are the vertices of of the graph
of the graph g and we have l labeled
bins they are different they are
the vertices of the graph h
and
we are asking
how how many how many times
each vertex of the graph h is used so
how many balls is going into that bin
so
this is this is this is a single
exponential
expression and our number of the
vertices was n divided by log n so there
is only two to the and divided by log
and ways of of dividing this number of
of the vertices of the graph uh
g
uh for
for four l label bins for the bins
representing the vertices of of the
graph h so we have obtained the same
lower bound but in easier way instead of
one complex reduction uh
of a one one-to-one reduction we are
obtaining uh
uh a reduction of the form one too many
but but still providing the same the
same lower bound in in an easier way
so
what we did
we we have allowed
uh by by those by by this by this
reduction one to many we we have allowed
uh one vertex of the graph h to be used
multiple times so in fact it is uh just
a
reduction one too many from graph
homomorphism to subgraph isomorphism
subgroup isomorphism
is a problem
when
where we can use one vertex of graph
h multiple times
so
so if it is if it is a reduction
then we can translate using this
reduction results the recent results
for graph homomorphism the recent lower
bounds for graph homomorphism to lower
bounds for subgraph isomorphism and in
such a way using a tight lower bound for
graph homomorphism we can we can apply
this reduction and obtain a tight lower
bound for subgraph isomorphism
okay
and moreover after all of that
we can get back to the channel
assignment and we can replace uh the
encoding in permutation
by this uh this kind of reduction one
too many and in this case we are getting
uh
compression step almost for free the
cost is in in taking many many different
instances instead of of one instance
and the rest of reduction is working the
same so
so now the reduction is is very similar
okay so thank you very much
last opportunity for questions in this
workshop
yes uh due to lower bounds for the
general assignment hold when you assume
things like the triangle inequality
if you assume triangle inequality it is
exactly the same as
as traveling salesman project problem or
something i i was thinking on it but
what it was exactly
tsp
the problem is not that well motivated
yeah it's not
the opposite of uh
triangular inequality
that's just a way of avoiding the
question
yeah but
we were thinking
on it and it yeah the problem reduced
to
tsp yeah it was exactly the sp i think
those two problems were the same in this
setting there was a bit quick on that
slide the bubbles n log log l
yes
you mean for the
version
yeah it is n times log local
so for example such an algorithm is
possible right for now we have
we have
square root here but maybe logarithm is
possible also
anything else okay then let's uh thank
the speaker again